peter but before before that happens
tell us about your trip to minnesota
well you know i really had no idea what
to expect mike
uh other than a clean environment if
somebody's gonna let you
into their training facility you have a
pretty good idea that they're going to
have the
they're going to put their best foot
forward this is the first time i've been
on an airplane in 137 days
all of that went well the traveling went
fine
and at the vikings facility what was so
interesting to me and i wrote about this
in my column in
football morning in america is that the
first thing i see
is that poor mike zimmer is coach of the
vikings he doesn't have a parking space
anymore because
there are there's a huge trailer park
there
and in that trailer are four medical
technicians
in four bays ready to take your
mid nasal swab and your covid19 test
obviously now we know for the first two
weeks
of training camp in the nfl these will
be daily
tests then after that it's just touring
the facility
i'd say the two points that really stood
out to me
is that if you've been in a modern
nfl locker room you know that these
things are taj mahals they're palaces
the minnesota vikings locker room is 6
500 square feet
that's twice the size of most
midwest suburban american homes
but but you go in there and they've
already taken out
all of the couches in this place which
is so beautiful
and they have made it so that every
locker
has two empty lockers around it so it's
just every other locker that is
uh you know going to be occupied so
that's the first thing and i think the
second thing
is that i think every team
is going to have this issue particularly
in facilities that are not as lavish and
not as
new as the vikings facility is here's
the problem
meeting space so it is going to be
a rule in every facility in the country
that no one ever sits within
six feet of someone else so
imagine that like they had an offensive
line meeting room that used to
be able to fit 20 people and now
you know that's been cut almost in half
the linebackers
a 14-seat room now is going to be a
maximum of eight
so that is the kind of thing one of the
team meeting rooms
for the minnesota vikings is going to be
chairs
out on their indoor practice field so
those are the kind of things but again
look
you know you knew this was not going to
be a normal year
under any circumstances and that's what
i found on my trip to minnesota
level of 1-10 with 10 being the highest
how
safe do you think an environment like
that
is going to be as relates to limiting
the spread of the virus understanding
that eventually they're going to be on a
football field where they're all
intermingling their breath and their
coughing and they're spit and whatever
but in the facility itself how safe do
you think the players will feel
they should feel nine at least if they
obey the rules
um and and again mike look here
here's the issue you know there are two
there's two issues actually
you know players basically if
even if they test in the morning
and they're going to get the results
back they're not going to get the
results back for 24 hours
so you could you could be positive and
just not be
told you were positive you could go out
on a practice field
you could have your hands on other
players at some point it's going to be
football okay and so other people
could then you know uh obviously become
symptomatic because of contact with you
but just as far as the facility itself
you know yeah i told eric sugarman when
i left there i said man
you can eat off the floor in here and
and you really can that
that part of it is going to be fine it's
what happens at practice when people are
putting their hands on each other and
what happens after 5 p.m mike
what happens if you know rookies 22
23 young players any player just even
goes out to an innocent dinner or goes
out to a bar or whatever
you know that is what the risk is these
nfl players are not going to be in a
bubble
so peter here's my big question i mean
because it sounds like you you
you think the medical people and
everybody like that are optimistic
you know but i want to dive into a
little bit about you know the coaching
aspect and i don't know how much
conversation you got there but
you know what's the overall feeling
you're getting whether it was in
minnesota or other coaches right now
because
that's something we brought up earlier
in the show like what do you do
when half your offensive line room has
to be in another room how are they gonna
deal with some of these issues that
you know you're talking about with the
the social distancing and all that
i think most teams chris are gonna do a
lot of uh
you know zoom and microsoft teams video
conferencing
right they're going to have i think most
teams will have their big
team meetings uh maybe after the first
one
i think they're going to have their big
team meetings on video conference
uh just because especially in training
camp you can't have 80 people in the
same place
unless as i say you put 100 chairs
uh spaced out all over a practice field
and you have the coach with a microphone
so everybody can hear him i could see
that
but chris i think the biggest issue
that and you raised this issue i think
the 16 person practice squads as mike
wrote about
yesterday the 16 person practice squads
in my opinion are really going to have
to
almost be quarantined in and of
themselves
if i was a coach and
i was gonna bring a guy on the practice
squad
i would have rules for guys on the
practice squad almost
liberty limiting rules on the practice
squad
hey at the end of the day today you go
back to your hotel
room we're going to pay for you to get
room service dinner and room service
breakfast
we don't want you leaving the room you
know and those are the kind of things
they're going to have to do
what are you going to do with your
backup quarterback i don't think your
backup quarterback should be within 20
feet
of anybody during the course of of the
of the day you know because you know
he's got to be ready he's one of the
most important guys
on your roster now your third string
quarterback now in my opinion
has to be the scout team quarterback not
the backup quarterback
your backup quarterback has to be kept
in a pristine environment in my opinion
and the one other thing
that you mentioned yeah i think that
when you have
a practice squad now you have to think
about it
mentally that if one position group on
your team
gets gets really savaged right you need
to be specifically
smart about each one of those position
groups
and on your practice squad whether you
want to have two or three linebackers on
that or not you have to have it
because if your linebackers get
decimated you got to be ready to play
okay so my just my follow-up to all that
because that was great stuff and i know
you know a lot of coaches in football
you know how how far down the line do we
think coaches are right now
and fortifying some of their plans and
also on that like
how how frustrated are the coaches that
they don't really know the rules of
what's going to be going on here at
training camp quite yet
i talked to one coordinator on friday
chris
and i asked him hey what's going on he
goes i don't know and i was just kind of
throwing out a
a fishing line he goes i don't know
when i'm going back to work i don't know
when practice is going to start
we have not had a single any indication
uh from their head coach you know
when practice is going to start and
especially for teams
who are in that are in flux right like
what do you do for instance if you're
the patriots somebody asked me over the
week
yesterday so you really don't think that
cam newton is a lock to start
and i said no i don't i mean
josh mcdaniels has not been in cam
newton's presence
right and it's july 21st whatever it is
today
i mean they don't even know he seems
healthy
but they haven't been with them in
practice and now when
are they going to be with them in
practice and chris
imagine you're an nfl coach and you're
told
the first 21 days of training you
haven't had any practice
any anything in the off season the first
21 days
of training camp at least that's what
the proposal was the first 21 days of
training camp
are all strength and conditioning you
know you're not going to have a
legitimate
football practice until the middle of
august
and three and a half weeks later by the
way you open your season
no one's touched anybody no one's put on
a pad
it's crazy and now you've got to play
games this is going to be a season
unlike any other season and chris i'll
just tell you one other quick thing yeah
i had a i had an executive the other day
tell me
flat out he said this is the year that i
will not be remotely surprised
if the detroit lions are holding the
lombardi trophy
at the end of the year nothing against
the detroit lions but i doubt many
people are picking them to win the super
bowl
his whole point was very simple
what team is going to handle covid the
best
what happens if if some teams are
ravaged by it
and what happens if some teams are
relatively untouched by it
those are the teams i think that have
the best chance to win
peter one thing that hit me between the
eyes yesterday when i read football
morning in america
beyond the fact that mike zimmer lost
his parking space to the bioreference
laboratory's trailer just the fact
that there is a dedicated
facility in the parking lot of the
vikings
where the players are going to enter to
be tested every day
and every team is going to have
something like this and every team is
going to have at least 120 tests per day
and those are going to be turned around
on a 24-hour basis and chris and i were
talking about this last hour
the league has glossed over the ethical
question of this
collective drain on resources that
otherwise could be devoted to members of
the general public who are symptomatic
who want their test results who need
their test results
we're going to have the nfl cutting the
line every day
every day every day with all the players
the coaches the trainers
the tier one and tier two personnel have
you gotten any sense
that people in the league are concerned
about have you got any sense or even
aware
of this of this impact that football is
necessarily going to have
on testing generally at a time when
testing is more necessary than ever
so mike you ask a great question there's
going to be early on in training camp
there will be about 5 800
tests per day devoted to nfl players
and team personnel that's a lot
i think the question that would have to
be asked is
and and we in in our little baileywicks
i think just don't really know the
answer
but let's just say for the sake of
argument that bioreference laboratories
was did not get this contract for the
nfl
would they then be taking those
5800 tests per day
that are devoted to nfl personnel and
with those 5800 tests
be used in let's say suburban houston
which is right now on fire or in phoenix
or
all over the state of florida which is
on fire that's
the thing i don't know and if if you
could tell me
assuredly that those tests would be
devoted to some of the places in the
country that
obviously need to have a ramp up in
testing
then i would say you know a pox on the
nfl i just don't know
if that is the case but here's the thing
peter
whoever they're using to collect the
samples whoever they're using to test
the samples those are people that could
be devoting their time
to testing the members of the general
puppy could be
you're right about that but why wouldn't
they be why wouldn't they be
what else are they gonna be doing if
they're i don't know the people who
would be providing those services to the
nfl
are able and available to provide the
services to members of the general
public
anything you do with the people who are
there to do that work is necessarily
taking them away from the general public
or would it just be more corporations
did taking it away so you don't know
that either i mean
to me hey we're flawed the whole set up
in the country's messed up
so you know i'm not going to sit here
and just blame the nfl for doing this
because i know there's other
corporations and businesses that are
starting to go down this line too
so i don't that to me is the biggest
thing like i hear you mike i'm not
trying to be insensitive
but i just you know there doesn't seem
to be a law of the land on any of this
right now and we're just kind of waiting
and can i can i just make one other
point about this
look if l and this is a big if
if it is deemed that the nfl i'm not
saying the nfl is an essential business
obviously it isn't
but if it is deemed that the nfl is
going to play
football okay one of the essential
things that happens and i agree
with daily testing okay if
it's going to happen if the nfl is going
to play
this is one of the things that has to
happen so if it does have to happen
then you have to accept the fact that
5800 tests per day
for now are going to be taken up by nfl
teams now
that'll eventually uh be reduced to
about 4 000 but still and it may not be
every day but still it's a monstrous
number of tests and i get the cynical
aspect of it but if people want to watch
nfl football this fall
they have to mentally get it straight in
their heads that
they the players are gonna have to be
tested almost daily
and they're gonna it's gonna have to
happen for six months peter i am 95
certain i read this in your column
yesterday but i read your column at 4am
so i may be misremembering
do you have a sense as to when the
technology is going to get to the point
where they can do a mouth swab
and a faster turnaround for nfl players
because that would seem to be the key to
me we still have that doughnut hole of
24 hours before you get your result
it's essential is when when will we get
to that point have you gotten a sense
that that's coming at some point during
football season
they hey i the nfl and the players
association believe there's a very good
chance
that a reliable fairly instant test 10
or 15 minutes
that a reliable test daily test
is coming but right now they just don't
feel the uh the science
is reliable enough for this test to
happen
so they can't use it right now and i
don't think i
if i wrote anything about it i wrote a
sentence but they just don't have that
saliva test right now
or the pinprick test right now that that
they feel is even remotely reliable
peter you know like you mentioned just a
little earlier i mean hey we got we got
the testing process we're getting used
to all these type of things and
the social distancing all of it you know
the proposal of
maybe three weeks of just training
before that or
did you hear anybody in minnesota or
other coaches i don't want you to like
blame anybody or anything like that
but do you get a sense that executives
and football people
want things pushed back as far as the
start of the regular season
i i don't uh chris i i didn't get that
sense
and the reason that i didn't get that
sense
is because i think i'm sure there are
some coaches
excuse me who would love to see it get
pushed back but the problem is
pushing it back benefits what it bet
you're going to be more ready to play
football
but you're going to be pushing it back
into
what could be and what we've all been
told by dr fauci and others
is going to be another wave of this
disease
kyle rudolph of the vikings told me
something very interesting i said what
do you fear
and he said i i don't have any he's got
kids he said i don't fear going in there
i
i totally trust what the union and and
the league and
and and our athletic trainers including
uh eric sugarman
are going to do but he said what i fear
is an interruption of the season
right because we're all going to be in
good enough shape
maybe not right away okay but we're all
going to be in football shape and
whatever shape everybody's in
we're going to be in the season and all
that and then
if we have to go home and quarantine for
three or four weeks and we can't work
out in our in our normal gym
most guys don't have gyms in their
houses and so
you know what is going to happen if
after four weeks the nfl
takes a pause for four weeks and then
comes back how do you do that
that is the biggest reason and and chris
i'll say one other thing
there is a coach in this league who
basically
my i was told by one of the executives
on the team
who's basically taking a totally don't
worry
be happy approach to this because he
said this is the classic
test of control what you can control
right and if you're a head coach in the
league right now you
know that the vast majority of the
normal controllable things
are now out of your control so his whole
point basically as verbalized to me by a
member
of his executive staff is that he just
says hey guys
it's going to be the same idiotic rules
for everybody else
so let's just go out and do what we can
and try our best to win
peter last thing for me here i i'm done
this is one thing that just popped up as
you've kind of talked about this
are the you know are they ready for the
time constraints that are gonna happen
here like
are they gonna have like 90 guys okay
what if 90 guys all show up in that tent
right away in the morning
are they all you know just going to wait
in line until they get tested or are
they going to have
you know times for guys to come in
because in the nfl if you have 8 o'clock
team meeting
you know a lot of guys show up at 7 40
and things like that
so what's going to happen i guess there
and then the next thing i want to know
is
90 guys in training camp in the
showering situation i'm not trying to be
a pervert here
but showering in a normal facility is
hard you know
that to me is something that we haven't
talked about how are they going to work
that out too sorry i know i don't mean
to ask you everything but you're the
great wizard of the nfl so i figured you
got to answer
no no i and and chris i'll just tell you
this
i you know although i did not get swab
the other day when i was at the vikings
um this i think each one of these
tests is going to take less than 30
seconds right
um and so i believe that they're just
going to tell players
i should have asked this question but i
believe they're just going to tell
players hey look
show up at seven o'clock and or maybe
they'll do position groups you know
linebacker seven o'clock
running back 705 right however right
okay and you ask about the
uh the shower yeah this i found very
interesting
all right so in the vik i actually
walked
into the the the shower area of their
locker room
and what's going to happen is that every
other shower head
is going to be removed it wasn't removed
the other day
but every other shower head is going to
be capped so that there's going to be in
fact about 10 feet
in between each person who is showering
and so that really is going to be weird
because you're right
you can't all shower at once there just
isn't going to be
enough uh enough resources to all shower
at once
so i do think that that is going to have
to be staggered
when actual practice and drills end
for everybody on the team peter
excellent work last week in minnesota we
look forward to
what else you will be bringing to the
table now the football morning
in america is back following your annual
vacation
uh i learned a lot it was it was uh a
great great read
and uh we appreciate some of your time
this morning we'll talk to you soon
you're the man peter
good to be on with you guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports